yo sup guys so um it's pretty late right
now but there's this guy that wrote to
me he said that he worked as a quant and
said that I'm jump trading so now I'm
checking out his profile and oh wow
equals Harvard too
[Music]
welcome to the show dude and I'm not
gonna do like the typical intro because
I want this to be more of a casual
conversation yeah yeah
thanks for using the microphones that we
are microphone stand yeah yeah so can we
talk a little bit blunt yourself cuz um
like interesting yeah so this is Kate
okay ake a little kato AKA sab Kaito
Kaito Gambino just get it are you trying
to plug your channel right away just
like Trenton all right go okay so the
reason why I brought you here is because
you have a very impressive resume you
know from what I understand you worked
at Citadel Instagram jump to trading
yeah these these are all like companies
that got rejected from exempt very so
can you tell me like why did you want to
come here yeah I did want to plug my
channel but I also didn't want to
provide the content for like people
because I saw your brothers interview
about quant
and it's like provide for the content
about the quant and also show a side of
people in the quant or tech spaces that
are non-traditional like me like I want
to show I want to present that there are
these people who exist so what do you
mean like you I can't I can't tell
what's so special about you yeah where
did you go to college and where did you
study
yeah so I did my undergrad and Harper
and then so I study my bachelor's in
computer science and my master's in
statistics oh you have a master's - yeah
hey are you done school I'm that what
school not not going back any time okay
so are you are you working full-time on
YouTube now yeah oh you're working
full-time yeah I thought you were still
an intern no no I said okay so you work
full-time at YouTube yeah can't talk to
me a little bit about all your previous
internship till now I made the
transition from quant trading to the
text so I started out interning at said
ìdo and then jump and then on and I
transitioned into tech so before I start
forth in my youtube I interned at
Instagram as well yeah so so you did
Citadel first and shopping yeah okay
so I'd Citadel you were a quant yes so
what did you do that's the dough I was
into
I was looking into Treasury funds so
like one of the one of the popular
techniques and Quan is to look at
correlated financial products so usually
like a lot of like financial products
don't move in sync the market is not
perfect and so usually some when
something lutely
yeah someone's laggy so some sometimes
like one product moves and then like the
other product follows quickly after but
then if you're able to use core layer
financial products to predict the one
that you're interested in you would have
some alpha there so wait what was like
the commodities or securities that you
are trading other ones I was looking at
was pretty blonde Treasury bonds doing
interesting yeah okay
so and then it jumped rating it was it
again Treasuries so job training the
internship is a little bit different so
the beginning is like a little bit of
training for all the interns to like get
on the same page I'll kind of like gain
tree where they have yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's kind of like that yeah it's not
it's not fun it's more classes more
classes and then on there I worked on a
project where I was trading market
events so like market events are like
big time events where the market is
super unstable so like examples are like
quarterly earnings or like acquirements
if a company of course know what about
when like someone tweeted about obama
and it was like he was dead or something
was that like a alright profitable day I
guess people wouldn't expect that but
but yeah talk Twitter is something that
people also about sentiment to analysis
and stuff like that so because I
remember from what I understand for for
like kuan firms whenever there's a lot
of in like craziness or a chaos in the
market that's when you can profit the
most because there's a lot of like
exactly rationality yeah just the team I
the team I was always disappear Lee
trade-off of events like they they made
all their might disappear laments and
they're just yeah so how should you
prepare for those interviews like what
did they ask you
yeah so I think I think quite interviews
are I kind of look the most challenging
because they include coding questions
finance questions and a statistics
question and usually the coding
questions that have you done bit code
before yeah like like the website but
just in general yeah yeah so like
usually like software interviews are
like medium level problems but then like
the quant interviews are like medium or
hard level
I'm suing so it's not they're not even
asking just for like basic software
skills they're asking like for like
higher lower self skill like at that
point like it doesn't really make you a
better software in addition what test
are you intelligent once you get in like
the work that you do is like not as near
like as challenging and I was like the
interview poems mm-hmm but yeah I think
so you saw that like a fundamental
understanding of like some basic finance
concepts and then some stats kind of
stuff do you need to know just like
what's a portfolio or like what's a
stock yeah yeah we're like what was risk
where how do you measure risk or like
sometimes some of these basic thoughts
you don't have to be like as
sophisticated as it again right I think
it doesn't need to be like oh what's the
black Scholes model how do you derive
that probably not right they won't ask
you to derive it but if you don't know
what it if you know what it is you know
what it is yeah and then what about what
about stats like what kind of questions
they ask it's used you like your game
problems like by flip a coin so many
times are like how would i if I have
about your paper it yeah yeah something
like that would like you're stuck in
this room with this other guy there's
always like some very like like skier
pong with like you're stuck on an island
and then they say like you have these
different colored hats and like it's
like oh how would I arrange the hats
such diet escaped out of prison it's
like always like one of these like I get
like brain teaser like just like
strategy problems like if you're like
playing games against someone that type
of stuff so any extracurriculars you did
when you were in school that made you
lean into finance I actually didn't
really mess with the finance group so in
school I wanted to like make all my
extracurriculars like non-academic
related cuz like they're like obviously
like a lot of professional like clubs
like finance clubs tech clubs but I
didn't want to get in because then cuz
then like uh-huh you spend all your time
like building your career and then you
don't have time for like having fun it's
just so I didn't really join the clubs
yeah I hate it I hated that too because
when your identity is based on your
career or at least like that very narrow
minded career path
it's kind of boring yeah yeah and
honestly it doesn't make as good like
quants or data scientists or software
engineer
yeah as you would think yeah so so I'm
guessing you didn't music I started
music later in my senior year uh-huh but
then throughout college I like kind of
like I was looking a dance troupe oh
thank you pop it's like hip-hop / kpop
you want to became cool so why did you
switch why did I switch yeah because it
seems like you're a quant and now you're
what's our engineer yeah yeah yeah why'd
you switch where I switch lost a lot of
money there yeah I did lose a lot of
money so I think there's two two main
reasons so one big reason is like I have
a lot of time now to like work on music
stuff because like I think like a
special mollusk want like so it is busy
it is very busy it's very stressful
I I did want to find something that like
gives me more opportunity to like learn
more about myself I didn't want to just
like just like work all the time right
and then the second big reason was I did
think that the way finance people like
thought about things was like very
limited everything is like just for the
sake of money and like I felt it made me
feel like I was losing like some human
aspect but a lot of the people that you
do me are like kind of like like
emotionless yeah they kind of like act
pure logically yes yes very objective
yeah that makes sense yeah okay but I
hope you don't mind me asking how much
did you get paid as a citadel intern and
John breathing and Instagram I go look
among view huh I can look them up if you
want I go go go go go go go go okay I'm
gonna take a quick break and say some
stuff you know this video is sponsored
by audible so start your 30-day trial in
your first audio book is free go to
audible.com slash Joma or if you're in
the u.s. text Joma at 500 500 audible
content includes an unmatched selection
of audio books and other audio products
all right back to you Joma
so one audiobooks you guys should listen
to is quants which is quite relevant to
what we're talking about because it's
actually it's like it's like a true
story
and it's about all the og quants back in
the day how they took over Wall Street
for example Ken Griffin that was our
boss at one point really good audiobook
you should step you check that out so
yeah don't forget audible it's perfect
for the summer times when you're just
chilling at the pool so don't forget you
can get your 30 day free trial and one
free audiobook if you go on audible.com
slash coma or text coma at 500 500 if
you are in the u.s. so it was about it
was about on ten weeks so 2300 a week
and then Facebook I want to say it was
like eight K a month yeah that sounds
about right that sounds about right
okay so yeah so since you didn't do
extracurricular in Kuan how did you know
about Kuan or wanted being project I I
was kind of like always like in the math
competition community throughout like no
school in high school enough yeah so
like in the math competition space like
usually like you would have like you
want to send by is like like kids who
are like two or three years over the
nurse and like we always look up to them
and then in college we see like a lot of
our son buddies like either going to
like academic math or like software
quiet and usually like Quan is something
that's really popular with like the
competitive math people so I got
interested I got introduced to that and
then like the interview problems are
also like very representative like the
old problems that we used to deal won't
weird like in high school so it was very
natural and it's also like very
competitive like in nature so mix it
boss I guess you're always like good at
math and you compete in math and stuff
like that yeah did you score well in
those competitions are you familiar with
the u.s. competition all the media are
maybe they are so yes
and I'll just nod yeah yeah like the
furthest I got was to like the USA mo
which is like the USA not not the it's
about like 500 US students who qualify
it's part of like the it's part of like
it's part of like the track to like the
USA IMO team but I've never got that for
those two hours I see yeah but from what
I understand if you want to be in quant
you gotta be good at math I guess or do
you have any other tips for people who
want to be in quanta who want to be in
quanta for high school students or like
college student let's start from high
school then and then gonna talk about
college
you know if they started lying to be a
quality call yeah I really I really
don't like the idea of like telling
people like what to do because like a
lot of people they say like I aspire to
be X and then you say like I have steps
1 2 3 for you and then like and then
they follow those steps they say I read
that book I read that book by Snowden
I still didn't get it and it's all
because of you because you told me to
read that book so bad by Italian yeah no
yeah you feel me yeah yeah so but I do
think like in general like it still is
good to like get exposure to a
competitive math or just like get
exposure to like just like stepping
outside of like your like normal school
stuff because like I think like in
school like you don't get challenged
enough you know if you like your school
doesn't offer that competitive math so
that was like a very general approach
and honestly I believe you like [ __ ]
there's not one single path to like kuan
but can you just tell me like one kind
of path like what should you learn what
should you major in and then like what
extracurriculars you should if you don't
you chose some I know I hate responding
to messages to about how do you get to
summer in June how are you getting to
data science especially theater science
because for me I mean analytics and you
can do whatever you want to get
analytics it could be a business dude
you could be a consultant you could be a
math major computer science if you do
anything yeah but yeah just give them
like one little one little X few like
one little tap that at least
you did or like that you saw that your
people do okay calm most common path
easy oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah like
pretty much like high probability yeah
scoring myself okay okay do competitive
math in high school and then you're
looking smart you know don't be an idiot
I guess yeah college I guess the popular
majors will be either peer math applied
math computer science stats physics in
some cases I think a lot of pong places
love physics people for some reason and
then extracurriculars I mean you could
go up your way to do the finance stuff
but then I would suggest against because
I think those are more for like i
banking people yeah like where it's all
about networking and like these teach
you how to network with people they have
classes just purely just for that cuz
like that's like a critical part to your
like yeah career path yeah well I guess
that it's enough about Quan I want to
talk more about like your personal life
more about like your your career in
rapping or SAR as an artist I think for
every rapper I'm an Arab Ram the artist
but every rappers okay okay I'm gonna
stop you here yeah wait what's the
problem of calling you a rapper what's
the work problem it what's the focus
because I don't want to get dissed
I don't wanna drama [ __ ] I just I
just want to be an artist your career in
rapping as an artist okay so yeah once
you start that I stir that around my
senior year of college that's pretty
late I thought it would be earlier I
think I was always kind of into it and
then I think I think like in college
like there was like a dark moment in my
life and then I think I listen to Tupac
oh I like music does have the power to
like change your mood or like brighten
your day and so I I just kind of want to
contribute to that yeah so I see your
shirt
to the camera real quick this Frieza and
yeah so are you a weeaboo I think we
abou is more for non agents yes I love
anime yeah yeah so which one is which
ones do you like which ones do I like I
grew up with Naruto never know I think
like every detail what do you watch my
startup series
the Lyle account I watched like one or
some quick yeah yeah so let's talk about
music now so what so the music that you
make it's more like light music right
you have some bars show me yeah I think
like it's gonna be hard because like I
don't have a beat I don't have anything
but it's just a raw voice do you think
yeah let's try something all right
um bumping with Jonah in the studio hit
him up told him that we'd gone record a
video
Jonah is at Facebook I'm at YouTube
Jonah is at Facebook but he still do
YouTube pipe it up give it up for the
interview
hit the like you already gave up you hit
the sub if you liked the bars and if you
are new making six figures cashing out
only 22 thinking about after this gonna
get a tattoo probably of Jonah's face
think it's gonna make me cool
[Music]
that was pretty good now one shot one
shot Marshall yeah
one shot dreams I wrote all right okay
so it was gonna be embarrassing better
video okay doc let's be real all you
plebs want to be like me wanna be in
demand land jobs like me want to run up
at the term and code like me but ain't
none of you mope was brain good like me
popping pills Michael docent just to be
on my level but you broadcast monkeys
coming back for the devil still your
jobs to your girl I'll make you a
cuckold
I cut off oh no that's the last line is
not me then that one's Nicki Minaj and I
didn't finish it
oh yeah something like that okay then
you got some worse oh thanks bro yeah of
course - was like cold [ __ ] tailed a
team I need more monies I got Gucci
while you wear them company t's free
swag oh my god you're a code monkey keep
typing I caught shots like step curry
huh I use you your month average I'm the
Clippers in the game your average while
you climb the ladder I'm an Everest get
your severance find a job here's a
reference and then as I am you want a
big four I don't care for I got what you
want when I was a sophomore you're
hating on my fame but I never heard of
you you bitching all in black but the
[ __ ] you yeah I think this was over
the Nicki Minaj beat yeah yeah I'm gonna
be eyes I was actually like pretty good
oh yeah also thank you too Seth for
supporting this channel thank you so
much and then also there's one question
on Twitter which is oh hey doma can you
become a data scientist or analysts with
a business degree that is yes and I'll
just show you a proof of this person on
LinkedIn that I found okay we're done
actually this one also has a Bachelor of
Arts in film and she became a data
scientist at Facebook so I'm alright so
thanks for watching if you like this
video don't forget to Like and subscribe
and then if you like this guy don't
forget to Like and subscribe his channel
I mean he passed my bar so I'm down to
promote shadow what up this is Kato kid
I'm stealing all of Jonah's viewers so
if you [ __ ] with me just check out my
channel he's gonna put the thing so
check out my latest music video
[Music]
what kind of videos you out there stuff
with designer and wait what huh designer
no no no not that design like your
typical designer and flexing